θα είμασταν σωστεί στο ότι είχαμε αναλάβει εκείνη την περίοδον την την διοργάνωση των μικρό
χορών που ήταν για τις γυναίκες επαιζηνεθνική κύπρου θέλαμε να δείξουμε πράγματα ήταν και μες
στων κορών νοιώ τότε πήραμε και την πρώτη θέση και παράληλ έχαμε είχαμε και το
πρώτον ευρωπαϊκών πρώτα θύλμακόλυφας που εχε να κάνει με το τρία επιτρία το αθελμαντρία επιτρία
που ίθα διεξακόταν στη λεμεσ όπου και εκεί πήραμε την πρόκρηση κια πρώτη φορά στηντελική
φάσι η εθνική γυναικών όπόταν είχαμε πράγματα να σχοληθούμε που αφορούσε διοργανώσης και αυτόν το
επαμε έτσι μάνω στην πλάκαν τυλό βλέπουμε στο βλέπουμε μετά από τρεις ημέρες ποέστηρενίμεήλ και
μου λέει είναι ηαίτηση που χρειάζεται να κάνουμνγια να πάρουμε να πάρουμε το μάνιου άλλα
δηλαδή το τι χρειάζεται να κάνουμε δεν τουδο σα συμμασία απλά το υπόγραψα λέο ιεγώ
ξέρεις μαθαίνουμε η καινούρια πράγματα για ταλιμά αι στην μπορεία όθως σοβαρολογούσε και είχε ξεκινήσει
η διαδικασία και φθάσαμε στ ένα σημείον που έπρεπε να ποφασίσουμε αν θα πούμε στη
διαδικασία να διεκδικήσουμε ή ανδεθαμπεναγια να κάμναμε ντοπομενο βήμα χρειαζόμασταν κυκυβερνητικές εγγιησεις ότιν κυβέρνηση είναι
δίπλα από την ομοσπονδία γιατί είναι το δεύτερον είναι το δεύτρον μεγαλύτερον προϊών που έχει
υπαγκόσιμε μοσπονδια μετά τωτομοντων πας και την ετουρμπάσκε συναι πως έλουν να νιωθούν ότι υπάρχει
μια έναν καραντσία από την κυβέρνηση και τ δεύτερον ήταν πώς θα αποπως θα θα
βελτιώ να μετογύπεδο γιατί προαπετούντα ένας μην ένας ελάχει στο αριθμος α θες το πιο
εύκολον ήταν ο σχεδιασμός του κυπέδου το πιο δύσκολο ίτα πωςθα πίσει στην κυβέρνηση να
συεμπιστευτεί και και κατά την διάρκειαν του κορονοϊούντο ποιο φιλικό να τομον